bonjour François brille bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous président de
la CFE-CGC le syndicat des cadres et de
l'encadrement merci d'être notre invité
en étant ensemble pendant 20 minutes
pour une interview en partenariat avec
la presse régionale représentée par
Stéphane Vernet de westfrance bonjour
Stéphane bonjour bonjour et c'est
évidemment la grosse journée de
mobilisation aujourd'hui en 6e journée
de mobilisation quel est votre objectif
François Morel ce serait quoi en fin de
journée une mobilisation réussie pour
vous
en fait une mobilisation réussie ça ne
se mesure pas que le jour de la
mobilisation il faut aussi
observer ce qui s'est passé depuis
plusieurs jours la façon dont les gens
se préparent la façon dont ils en
parlent la façon dont ils se sentent
concernés par cette journée de
mobilisation et bien entendu à la fin on
va mesurer le nombre de personnes qui
sont venues ce qui s'est dit
l'entrain de chacun pour participer à un
événement qui est un événement social
important marquant je pense pour notre
époque et auquel un grand nombre de
personnes veulent participer vous pensez
que ce sera la journée la plus suivie
depuis le début de la mobilisation j'ai
fini par le penser parce que c'est ce
que tout le monde dit moi
personnellement j'ai pas plus de cas que
ça mais alors si bien entendu chacun
dans son organisation c'est le cas pour
la CFE-CGC à des petites remontées qui
lui reviennent de ces sections
syndicales de leurs capacité de leur
volonté de participer au mouvement après
ce ne sont que des capteurs ce n'est pas
la mesure objectiver de tout mais il y a
une grande volonté de participer à cette
journée aujourd'hui de cette marque
plus un million atteindre la barre de 2
millions c'est possible je pense que ce
sera ce sera dépassé la barre du million
on va à une avoir une mobilisation du
même niveau que la plus forte journée
qui je crois a été à la fin du mois de
janvier donc oui en plus écoutez plus on
verra il y aura probablement débat sur
la question entre les chiffres du
ministère et les chiffres des
organisations faudra viser un peu entre
les deux mais de toute façon ça restera
une grande journée oui qu'est-ce qui se
passe après quoi qu'il en soit c'est la
bonne question pour le coup
moi je vais vous dire ce que je souhaite
c'est que le Président de la République
le Gouvernement prennent la parole et
prennent la seule décision qui me paraît
être la bonne et la vraie décision
disponible de retirer le projet et de
continuer à aller de l'avant vous croyez
encore un retrait du texte oui moi je
pense effectivement pourquoi pourquoi je
pense ça parce que j'observe j'essaie
d'analyser les commentaires qui sont
faits sur cette question là et j'ai
entendu ce week-end dans une émission un
commentateur dit Emmanuel Macron ne peut
pas reculer parce que sinon son
quinquennat est foutu c'est vrai non
mais je crois tout l'inverse en fait je
crois tout l'inverse parce que j'ai
essayé moi aussi réfléchir je me suis
posé la question ceci mais finalement si
aujourd'hui le point de la République
fait machine arrière il s'agit bien de
cela si retire son texte puisqu'on le
sait il y a pas d'urgence à réformer sur
cette question là finalement c'est lui
qui sort par le haut parce qu'il nous
oblige nous les syndicats nous nous
avons pris nos responsabilités il prend
les siennes nous devons lui répondre à
ça et je pense tout le contraire
finalement c'est que ça ouvre le
quinquennat sur des perspectives de
discussions de réforme pourquoi pas
d'autres réformes en tout cas de de
travail ensemble pour pouvoir faire
avancer la société vous pourriez céder
sur certains points sur d'autres formes
c'est retirent
en fait moi je pense que dans notre
démocratie sociale moi je pense que dans
notre démocratie sociale les réforme
doivent se construire se penser se
travailler ensemble il y a des points
sur lesquels on peut être en marge ou en
désaccord mais ça fait partie aussi des
sujets de discussion et voir pourquoi
pas de compromis et de négociation c'est
notre métier on fait ça au quotidien
dans les entreprises et au niveau du
fonctionnement des différents
dispositifs qui organisent finalement la
société
on est tout à fait prêt à faire pareil
vous lui proposez quoi du
gagnant-gagnant s'il retire sa réforme
de la formule en tant que tel mais moi
je pense pour le coup que si
effectivement il retirait ce projet
aujourd'hui on ouvrirait tout d'un coup
dans notre pays des perspectives de
travail et d'avancer ensemble que je
crois personne ne peut soupçonner par
exemple bah écoutez sur la question pour
le coup qui est en débat j'entendais
tout à l'heure que vous en parliez de
l'emploi des seniors mais tout un tas
d'autres sujets et qui ont très au
travail et pourquoi pas aux questions
économiques
aux questions des dispositions de fin de
carrière aux questions de l'Emploi de la
Formation professionnelle qui sont des
sujets c'est-à-dire dans notre cœur de
métier à nous les organisations sur la
question du partage de la valeur ajoutée
sur les questions de la restructuration
de la façon de fonctionner des
entreprises de leur vision financière de
leur vision comptable de la façon dont
les aides de l'État sont organisés
vis-à-vis des entreprises des marchés
économiques etc vous savez de la
protection sociale bien entendu de la
maladie de l'hôpital on pourrait aussi
parler des sujets de l'éducation par
exemple de la transition énergétique
voir le travail qui va arriver là dans
les prochaines semaines portées par
Olivier du soft est-ce que vous dites on
sera peut-être plus dans le compromis on
sera peut-être plus apte à alors vous
n'aimez pas céder sur certains points
mais en tout cas plus actes à accepter
certaines choses du gouvernement si le
gouvernement fait sur la réforme des
retraites et a contrario s'il la retire
pas vous serez très dur sur cette loi
travail en fait pour tout vous dire moi
je suis un peu fatigué d'être toujours
en opposition avec le gouvernement et
j'ai du mal à interpréter cette époque
dans laquelle finalement le gouvernement
dans ces dans sa volonté de réformer qui
est nécessaire pour un pays qui veut
avancer qui doit s'adapter à son
environnement d'aller toujours plus dans
la simplification la réduction des
droits la mise sous tension finalement
du corps social moi je crois tout
l'inverse je pense que justement dans
notre
modernité qui est une modernité complexe
et bien il faut au contraire attirer à
soi les représentants des corps sociaux
ce qu'on appelle les corps
intermédiaires et les faits et
travailler ensemble avec le législateur
avec le monde politique pour justement
interpréter apprivoiser cette complexité
là et je pense que depuis 20 ans on ne
travaille pas suffisamment avec le
gouvernement parce que le gouvernement
travaille trop nous en fait or en fait
on représente les mêmes intérêts dans la
société les intérêts du développement de
la croissance moi je pense que le
progrès de tous n'est rien d'autre que
l'addition de la volonté individuelle de
progresser et donc il ne faut pas
anesthésier cette volonté de progresser
cette volonté individuelle et tout ça ce
sont des sujets sur lesquels il faut
qu'on travaille aujourd'hui avec le
gouvernement alors vous les travaillez
que le gouvernement mais il y a une
difficulté c'est un problème de de
déconnexion vous avez dit il y a
quelques jours les gens qui ont pondu
cette réforme ont lu Martine fait de
l'économie et oui oui dans le monde du
travail si vous avez baigné dans le
monde de l'entreprise de comprendrait sa
réalité ce qui n'est pas là le fond du
problème c'est tout à fait ce que je
pense et tout à fait ce que je pense je
pense que moi je ne fais pas d'attaque à
de personnes mais simplement le problème
c'est qu'effectivement les politiques
publiques sont pensées sont construites
par des gens qui n'ont pas une
connaissance suffisante de ce qu'est le
monde du travail le monde de
l'entreprise des réflexes
prendre de la RATP elle connaît un peu
le monde de l'entreprise
sa carrière de polytechnicienne comme ça
se faisait à une certaine époque comme
ingénieur de production dans une usine
si elle avait travaillé sur des
chantiers à 25 ans je pense que je
n'aurait pas la même vision de
l'entreprise vous savez quand on est
quand on est bombardé patron de boite à
45 ou 50 ans moi je prétends mais je
suis prêt à en discuter je peux me
tromper qu'on n'a pas tout à fait la
même vision de l'entreprise de la façon
qu'elle a de fonctionner que si on a
commencé et bien sur le terrain à
comprendre ce que c'est que les
différentes dimensions l'entreprise la
dimension de l'organigramme qui est à
plat la dimension sociale ce que sont
les réflexes des gens dans des
organisations complexes comment ils se
motive comment il se démotivent vous
savez c'est très facile de mettre un
atelier à l'arrêt tout simplement quand
on n'est pas motivé quel que soit son
niveau de responsabilité et ça quand on
l'a pas vécu au quotidien dans sa chair
on peut pas le comprendre on prend des
décisions qui sont et on pense que tout
d'un coup tout va s'appliquer comme par
miracle ben non en fait c'est pas comme
ça que ça marche vous avez des contacts
récents avec Elisabeth borne
non paraissant vous savez on a eu cet
échange téléphonique il y a deux
semaines maintenant je crois que c'était
un dimanche
qui est un contact comme toujours avec
Elisabeth borne je trouve de très grande
qualité
j'ai avec Elisabeth borne
personnellement et au nom de mon
syndicat des relations qui sont des
relations de qualité elle est dans son
rôle moi je suis aussi dans le mien elle
a un mandat celui du président de la
République de faire quelque chose
auquel moi je ne crois pas mais au moins
ce qu'il y a de bien avec elle je veux
le redire ici c'est que
je crois elle nous respecte voilà le
respect et c'est que le dossier n'est
pas complexe nous avons des points de
désaccord mais nous a jamais pris pour
des quilles dans cette affaire c'est
quand même plutôt oui d'autres oui oui
très clairement ne croyez pas du tout au
dialogue social et nous avons avec lui
avec lui une période assez difficile oui
c'est pas le cas d'Elizabeth borne je
pense qu'elle est assez dans la ligne de
Jean Castex c'est-à-dire elle elle croit
effectivement à l'efficacité du dialogue
social on est là pour le coup sur un
sujet où on est difficilement
réconciliable à ce stade le porte-paro
le gouvernement vous a un petit peu
agacé la semaine dernière quand il a dit
que mettre le pays à l'arrêt c'était
prendre le risque d'une catastrophe
écologique agricole sanitaire voire
humaine dans quelques mois vous avez
vous êtes vous êtes redescendu ou lui on
voulait toujours alors si vous voulez
moi j'ai pris un engagement c'est de ne
plus que commenter les propos d'Olivier
Vérand et avoir beaucoup fait voilà j'ai
beaucoup fait en fait si vous voulez je
veux améliorer mon bilan carbone en ce
moment et il paraît que la communication
sur les réseaux sociaux les tweets les
retweets etc ça consomme beaucoup de de
megabits donc voilà je préfère ne pas ne
plus commenter les fulgurances
hallucinatoires de Livier Véran je pense
que il a besoin d'un peu de repos mais
bon voilà le printemps arrive on va
avoir des jours meilleurs peut-être que
lui il va redescendre pour le coup la
CGT parce que il y a quand même une
expression à laquelle réagit Elizabeth
Bank d'ailleurs la CGT veut mettre
l'économie à genoux est-ce que c'est une
expression que vous reprenez à votre
compte non pour le coup non moi je m'en
tiens à ce qui a été dit dans
l'intersydicale on est parti prenant de
l'intersyndical on fait des communiqués
qui sont dosées au trébuchet et moi je
m'en tiens ce qui était dit mettre la
France à l'arrêt pour le 7 mars pourquoi
mais parce que il y a eu 5 mobilisations
quand même de grande ampleur qu'on
marquait quelque chose d'important dans
le mouvement social en France et on a
laissé trois semaines au gouvernement et
au président de la République pour
réagir moi je trouve que le mouvement il
est assez exemplaire tout le monde l'a
remarqué il est graduel et pas en trois
semaines on a eu droit à quoi en fait on
a eu droit à deux déclarations du
président de la République une Rungis et
l'autre au salon de l'agriculture ou
pour tout dire il se fout quand même un
peu de nous il appelle au bon sens etc
mais enfin bon sens c'est pas sérieux il
fait comme s'il n'y avait pas eu un mois
et demi de mobilisation comme si les
arguments du gouvernement n'avaient pas
été totalement démonté par les experts
on a gagné la bataille de l'opinion
pourquoi on a gagné la bataille de
l'opinion parce qu'on a gagné la
bataille des arguments sur la pension
minimale sur la carrière longue
s'agissant de la situation faite aux
femmes dans le dispositif etc on a eu
raison surtout en fait et moi je pense
que le gouvernement en tout cas le
président de la République aurait pu
avoir un peu d'humilité il aurait pu
venir vers nous en disant bon écoutez il
se passe quelque chose comme il l'avait
dit d'ailleurs au mois d'avril 2021 si
vous en avez souvenir il a fait un très
beau discours à la sortie du covid
manuel Macron fait de très beaux
discours et donc et il nous disait j'ai
compris j'ai changé etc bah moi
j'aimerais bien qu'il reprenne un peu
l'esprit de ce discours de la précovide
et qui disent ben voilà j'ai vu ce qui
se passe j'ai compris j'ai changé sur
l'économie à genoux vous dites vous
reprendrez pas cette expression mais
dans les faits que vous souhaitez des
blocages est-ce que vous souhaitez des
grèves reconductibles non l'appel c'est
pas un appel à la grève reconductible
mais c'est un appel à ce que la journée
de mobilisation du 7 mars ou une journée
marquante et y compris bien entendu dans
les arrêts de production dans les
manifestations visibles du soutien au
mouvement
ça peut être une fermeture temporaire
d'un commerce ça peut être différents
événements le long des cortèges etc
parce que la CGT annonce ce matin que
les expéditions de carburant sont
bloquées dans toutes les raffineries du
pays vous soutenez ça vous savez quand
un mouvement de grève est déclaré
moi-même dans mon organisation certains
de mes collègues sur le terrain vont
décider d'être dans une intersey
syndicale qui appelle à la grève et le
principe de la grève c'est quand même
d'arrêter la production donc oui mais
qu'aujourd'hui l'appel c'est pour
aujourd'hui le 7 mars
il y a quand même un certain nombre de
trains qui sont déjà annulés de manière
préventive toute la semaine donc on est
il y a un certain nombre de d'acteurs de
cette grève qui sont déjà dans la
logique d'une grève reconductible
est-ce que ça c'est pas de nature à
fracturer ou diviser le légion syndicale
vous décriviez je vais répondre à votre
question le moi mon souhait donc ici le
président de la CFE-CGC moi mon souhait
c'est que la journée du 7 mars soit une
journée marquante et y compris bien
entendu dans l'impact économique qu'elle
peut avoir parce que ce que je crois
c'est que ayant finalement échoué à
convaincre le Président de la République
qu'il devait changer son projet
il faut activer un des paramètres qui
peut peut-être l'influencer à savoir le
pouvoir économique j'entends rien en
disant ça tout le monde le sait et nous
moi-même je le sais puisque je rencontre
bien entendu des employeurs ce qu'on
appelle les grands patrons etc et je
leur dis je leur dis mais quand est-ce
que vous prenez votre téléphone vous
appelez l'Elysée vous leur dites
maintenant ça suffit parce que la vérité
c'est que les employeurs que ce soit le
Medef la CME ou l'UEP ils en voulaient
pas de cette réforme c'est ça la vérité
d'ailleurs avant qu'on leur donne ce
chèque de 8 milliards d'euros par la
suppression de la cotisation sur la
valeur ajoutée des entreprises il
s'exprimait pas pour la réforme c'est ça
la vérité mais bon bien sûr quand ils
ont eu leur huit milliards
il est obligé de faire un communiqué en
disant cette réforme c'est super mais
nous on sait que personne n'y croit
vraiment et d'ailleurs c'est logique ces
employeurs notamment les très grandes
entreprises qui se débarrassent de leur
salarié à partir de 58 ans c'est pas
avec le sourire qui vont comprendre
qu'il va falloir qu'il les garde deux
ans de plus donc franchement mais pour
répondre à votre question effectivement
nous on souhaite que ce mouvement soit
graduel et qu'il y ait un moment où le
gouvernement ou le président de la
République nous répondent enfin prennent
la main et nous disent écoutez voilà
j'ai compris il se passe quelque chose
il faut quand même qu'on parle un peu
parce que visiblement il y a une
décision importante à prendre et donc il
faut trouver des moyens d'être quand
même alors le texte est actuellement
examiné au Sénat l'article 7 sera
examiné en fin d'après-midi
sans grand suspense il sera adopté à ce
que ça va pas affaiblir votre
mobilisation
non pourquoi ça va moi je pense ça va
affaiblir la représentativité de cette
instance respectable qui est le Sénat
parce que c'est quand même compliqué de
constater d'être obligé de constater
qu'alors que la réforme est rejetée par
trois Français sur 4 par 9 personnes qui
travaillent sur 10 une assemblée qui est
censée représenter les territoires les
Français va voter pour ce projet voilà
c'est tout j'ai pas d'autre comme
mentais à faire moi je pense que alors
le message a passé au sénateur je fais
que ça depuis deux mois j'en ai
rencontré j'ai pas fini d'en rencontrer
le message il est clair il est de dire
écoutez écoutez les gens qui vous ont
élu tout simplement après moi j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour le monde
politique bien entendu oui je rencontre
tous les groupes les responsables de
groupes que ce soit l'assemblée au Sénat
il est probable que cette semaine je
vais en rencontrer encore
et je leur dirai rencontrer certains
députés à l'air dont Aurélien Pradier ce
matin vous irez vous aussi demain matin
pardon pas avec lui mais j'ai bien
l'intention de le rencontrer comme j'ai
rencontré la plupart des responsables de
groupe sur le sujet ou d'autres
personnes chez les républicains ou non
matériaux alors lui précisément non mais
je vois que vous êtes très incisif sur
mon agenda mais je vous confirme que
j'ai rencontré beaucoup de personnes et
je vais vous dire quel est mon objectif
quand je les rencontre mon objectif
c'est de les faire douter mon objectif
c'est de les faire douter c'est normal
je leur dis écoutez je ne comprends pas
moi je représente des gens qui dans les
entreprises ont des responsabilités
compte un attachement syndical que je
connais avec qui je parle et avec eux je
suis contre cette réforme voilà mes
arguments
moi j'aimerais un peu vous faire douter
parce qu'on a un problème parce que si
vous vous êtes pour vous devez avoir des
arguments et bien on va discuter on va
les confronter oui argument de gauche ne
passe pas depuis le début de l'examen du
texte au Sénat en l'occurrence
de gauche ce sont des arguments
syndicaux suppression c'est-à-dire les
arguments de suppressions
de les faire douter bien entendu mais si
vous voulez ce qui se dresse devant moi
qui est un peu comme un mur mais vous
savez le mur à force de les corner on
finit toujours par le percer un peu
c'est en fait le discours politique qui
part nature même est idéologique qu'on
soit de gauche ou de droite ou du centre
ou d'Emmanuel Macron peu importe il y a
toujours une nature idéologique dans un
discours politique or moi je suis
représentant d'une organisation
syndicale qui est totalement
indépendante de tout parti politique et
totalement déconnecté de tout
apparentement idéologique moi mon truc
c'est la défense de l'encadrement de la
responsabilité de l'engagement
professionnel donc moi je parle à tout
le monde j'ai pas de problème vous
voulez faire doter les sénateurs mais ce
qu'ils sont en train de faire ne vous
fait pas douter vous par exemple dans
les dans les aménagements qui ont été
proposés il y a il y a le vote d'un CDI
senior une mesure à laquelle vous
souscrivez pas du tout non moi je crois
pas du tout à l'efficacité de de ce
genre de choses nous à la cfeugc ce
qu'on a proposé pour les seniors parce
qu'en fait c'est le sujet c'est le sujet
qui apporte le plus de ressources au
dispositif pas la totalité mais en tout
cas c'est au moins les deux tiers de la
ressource nécessaire quand on se met
dans le cadre budgétaire tel qu'il a été
défini c'est le maintien nous on a
proposé un objectif de maintien de
100.000 seniors qui aujourd'hui
stationne à Pôle emploi et donc sont à
la charge de la collectivité avant de
pouvoir faire valoir leurs droits à la
retraite et pour ça il y a des moyens et
les moyens c'est de proposer un
dispositif nous on a proposé à partir de
55 ans dans lequel les gens dans la
dernière partie de carrière peuvent
inscrire un projet professionnel entre
guillemets allégé c'est-à-dire moins de
charges opérationnelles plus de
disponibilité vers le tutorat vers
l'encadrement
la mobilisation finalement de leur
expérience et plus de temps disponibles
vis-à-vis de leur environnement ça peut
être les voisins la famille les
associations finalement c'est une
avancée en biseau vers la retraite nous
on croit énormément à ce dispositif un
dispositif pour lequel l'État pourrait
intervenir à la faire à travers un
certain nombre de moyens aujourd'hui il
y a plus de 200 milliards qui sont
déversés vis-à-vis des entreprises sans
condition des discriminations nous on
pense qu'on pourrait travailler sur des
dispositifs incitatifs d'une autre
efficacité que le fameux CDI senior le
Sénat votera l'article 7 ça ne fait plus
aucun doute en tout cas il y aura un
vote sur cet article est-ce que vous
souhaitez qu'il y a un vote final sur le
texte
moi je souhaite toujours que
l'examen est donc l'engagement des
personnes qui détiennent un mandat à son
terme moi j'ai pas de problème par
rapport à ça j'ai regretté avec mes
collègues que le débat à l'Assemblée
n'aille pas à son terme mais ceci dit je
veux remarquer quand même quelque chose
c'est que qui a contraint le débat dans
un terme extrêmement court de timing
c'est le gouvernement qui a choisi cette
option c'est le gouvernement qu'il a
choisi après moi je suis pas tellement à
juger des positions de tel ou tel je
connais mal le fonctionnement de
l'Assemblée je connais pas très bien le
fonctionnement du Sénat en tout cas
l'école que les gens ont entre eux mais
j'aurais préféré effectivement que le
vote Aya son terme comme je souhaite
qu'il aille à son thermocella un dernier
mot Stéphane est-ce que est-ce que
est-ce qu'il y a une nouvelle journée de
mobilisation prévue si oui quand et
quand est-ce que vous allez décider de
cela ce soir oui on va en décider ce
soir et je dois vous dire que même si je
connaissais la réponse de toute façon je
pourrai pas vous la donner mais à ce
stade
rien n'est prévu de façon définitive
tout ça va se faire aujourd'hui en
fonction de la mobilisation on se parle
puis vous savez en tête de cortège
finalement on est dans un coin
tranquille on peut discuter entre nous
en échange beaucoup merci beaucoup merci
d'avoir été notre